this is episode 1 of the warrior kid
podcast ask Uncle Jake
good morning echo good morning
and we're putting that together this
podcast for kids this is a podcast for
kids specifically this is a podcast for
warrior kids based on the book the way
of the warrior kid and we're going to
talk about that book and basically
answer a bunch of questions that a bunch
of kids asked so first of all really
quickly if you don't know anything about
the warrior kid don't know who uncle
Jake is don't know who I am and don't
know who EKKO is really quickly my name
is Jo willing I was born and raised in a
little New England town on the dirt road
and I joined the Navy when I was 18
years old and I went into the SEAL Teams
and I stayed in the SEAL Teams for
twenty years I had a great time I love
my job I worked with a bunch of great
people people that were in the SEAL
Teams people in the army
people in the Navy people in the Air
Force and the Marine Corps I fought in
the war in Iraq and it was an honor to
be there with so many brave men and
women and I eventually retired from the
Navy and now I have a business where I
teach people about leadership and I live
out here in California and I have four
kids of my own now uncle Jake he's one
of the characters in the book way the
warrior kid and a lot of people think
Uncle Jake is me but that is actually
not true uncle Jake is a fictional
character which means he isn't real and
it but but even though he's not real in
real life he's real in my head so when I
wrote about him it was very easy for me
to write about him because I kind of
knew what he was like he's uncle Jake is
kind of
that I always tried to be uncle Jake's
better than me he's the the ideal seal
meaning that he has the characteristics
that I think the best seal would be like
I was certainly not the best seal I
tried my best but it's a hard job and
even though I don't know even though I'm
not quite as good as uncle Jake is in
many respects in many respects not even
close but I do know how he thinks
and that's why I think I'll be able to
answer some of the questions that people
had for Uncle Jake and then lastly echo
Charles he is a friend of mine from
jiu-jitsu who is really good with
computers and video cameras and voice
recorders and he helps me make all these
podcasts and the reason that we know
each other is from training jiu-jitsu
which he's been training for a long time
in jiu-jitsu and that's how we know each
other and he has two little warrior kids
of his own how old are they echo
currently nine months and four years
little kids one girl in one boy I have
three girls and one boy and my oldest
girl is about to graduate from high
school and my youngest daughter is in
second grade so that's my that's who I
am and like I said this is a podcast for
kids and you all sent a bunch of
questions and I definitely appreciate it
I appreciate that you all you kids put
pictures of yourselves doing a bunch of
things that are good for you reading a
book which is awesome you sent pictures
of you doing pull-ups doing push-ups
studying making times tables all those
things and and I really enjoyed seeing
all these kids doing all those things
that are good a lot of times you hear
about kids doing things that are bad and
this was a complete opposite of that
kids doing things that were good so I
got a bunch of questions and I'm going
to just try and answer them as quick as
I can
thank you for asking them so here we go
I'm going to get right into it
Nathan wanted to know when the next
warrior kids book is coming it's coming
in May of 2018
Benedict wanted to know how many books I
have and how many I've read already I
have a lot of books I don't know the
number but I have a lot of books I read
books all the time and when I went to
college I actually studied English which
means I read even more books I didn't
keep all those books I kept some of them
the ones that I liked I kept the one
that I didn't like I got rid of them and
it but right now I would say I have a
few hundred books and I've read probably
a little bit well probably around half
of them some of them I only refer to but
yeah the more you read the smarter you
get so keep reading next how does a
seven year old deal with bullying
physical bullying and being left out of
groups so this is the best way I think
to deal with bullying DuPont's that's
one thing
dude you Jitsu study learn read and with
all those things the better you get at
those things the more confident you'll
be then the more confident you are the
less bullying occurs now sometimes
you're going to get bullied everybody's
going to get bullied I got bullied when
I was a kid it happens there's always in
it and I even see adults that get
bullied even it's not quite the same but
some people have a boss that's a bully
or they're in a relationship with a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or a husband
and wife and they can be bullies so
bullying happens all the time and you
you got to learn to deal with it but
some of the best things you can do is
try and make yourself better by working
out by studying by learning and those
things will help you gain confidence and
when you gain confidence there's less
bullying now as far as being left out of
groups that's not that big of a deal
because you know what it's okay to be
alone sometimes and if there's some
people that are out there that don't
want to hang around with you find some
other people to hang around with
and if there's no one to hang around
with that's okay to go hang around with
a book go hang around with a pull-up bar
that's okay it's not always fun but
sometimes that's the way it has to be
sometimes there's no kids around that
are interested in the same things as you
so that's no big deal all right next
question
do you get a lot of Ali's uncle Jake
well yes I do get some Ali sometimes
well uncle Jake rarely gets hurt Jaakko
me I get hurt sometimes right now I have
a broken knuckle which is bothering me I
cut my foot last night for no reason
which is bothering me and I have a
little tweaked knee that's what's going
on with with Jaco right now uncle Jake
gets hurt a little less than Jocko
but everyone get hurt everyone's a human
and who taught uncle Jake to be a
warrior kid when he was four years old
and those questions are from Zacky we're
gonna get into Uncle Jake and how he
grew up but Uncle Jake wasn't born a
warrior he wasn't born a warrior kid he
had to become a warrior kidney kind of
talks about that in the book he couldn't
do a bunch of pull-ups before he joined
the military he couldn't do a bunch of
pulps he had to learn he didn't know to
be smart he had to learn how to study so
we'll talk about that in some of the
future warrior kid books next up how
often could you have a treat without
falling for the sugar-coated lies and
that's from Durham age 11 sometimes you
can have treats for sure and you just
have to make sure that you're not going
overboard and going crazy with the
Snickers bars and the Cheetos echo knows
that that I eat Cheetos sometimes yes
they have bags of Cheetos in our in our
office where we record this and so
sometimes I grab a bag of Cheetos and
the thing is you just got to be careful
that you don't go overboard with stuff
so if you want to have an occasional
make sure that you earn it that's one
thing I like to do is I like to make
sure that I earn it meaning I'm going to
work out hard before I delve into the
sugar-coated lies just be careful good
way to look at that and how I go over it
with my daughter is
things like Cheetos and M&Ms and all
these things they make you weak other
food to make you strong so yeah if you
eat a bunch of strong foods if you have
some Cheetos sure it's going to make you
weaker but you'll still be strong
overall yeah so it gives them an idea
you know they're like eating a bunch of
strong food you're still going to
maintain that strong Ness right right
and then okay so everyone's in like you
can have some weak foods but you'll
still be stronger more weak food you
have the weaker you're going to get yes
and you don't want to let the weak food
to be more than the strong foods really
then you're going to be weak instead of
being strong yeah or even even because
you eat a bunch of strong foods you get
all strong and they need a bunch of weak
foods then now you're back to zero yeah
we don't be zero no we don't all right
leave I sent a video question that was
pretty funny and a good question how
many pull-ups push-ups sit-ups burpees
should I be able to do by the end of
summer and I had asked him back how many
can you do right now and he said he
could do five pull-ups 14 push-ups 36
sit-ups and he didn't know how many
burpees and so I answered him back and
said he should try for 12 pull-ups 35
push-ups 60 sit-ups and 30 burpees in
two minutes
and he said thanks for helping with his
exercises so that's something that
everyone's going to want to know is how
many should I be able to do well it's as
many as you can and you're always
working to try and get one more that's
what I'm always doing so if you can do
for hopefully next week you can do five
once you can do five hopefully week
after that you can do six you're always
trying to build and get stronger and
what's really nice about being a kid is
that you're able to keep getting
stronger and stronger and stronger for
years and years and years once you're an
old man like me then it's harder to make
those gains yeah but that's okay we
still keep working because otherwise we
start going backwards yeah and we don't
want to do that next one from Colin I'm
14 so I guess I'm still considered a kid
love to know what would happen if you
ever took a day off from your routine I
guess he means by my routines working
out and getting up early and if that
happened you know I would just have to
get back on the routine the next day and
I think what you have to watch out for
is you take a day off and then that
turns into two days off and then that
turns into a week and then that turns
into a month and then the next thing you
know you've been off your routine
kid you're not getting stronger you're
getting weaker you're not getting
smarter you're getting dumber
you don't want that you be next one you
beat the Sun up every morning what time
you go to sleep and how important is
rest and nutrition to a war your kid
rest and nutrition is really important
and you should sleep a lot that's what
makes you recover that's what helps you
grow especially kids that are still
growing you need to get as much sleep as
you can so go to bed I'll tell you when
you go to bed go to bed when you feel
tired and a lot of times this these days
that means putting away the iPhone and
the iPad and stuff that keeps you awake
for no reason
put those things away and go to sleep
because when you're going to sleep
you're getting stronger next one my
little warrior wants to know if all kids
have to Train Brazilian Jujitsu are
there other options she's in another
sport for ten hours a week well the most
important thing and that's great is that
she's training and she's training hard
and there's all kinds of sports in all
sports are good for you and it's good to
train hard in sports and it's good to
focus on sports so you don't have to
train jiu-jitsu to be a warrior that
being said if you get the chance try and
take a little jiu-jitsu and I'll tell
you why because one thing that jiu-jitsu
will give you that other sports won't
give you is the means to defend yourself
and stand up for yourself as someone's
picking on you or bullying you so it is
important to train jiu-jitsu but if
you're training really hard in other
athletics you might not be able to do as
much as you want but that's okay just
try and squeeze in a little bit so you
know how to take care of yourself and
defend yourself good for autonomy as
well so like if you play team sports it
there is this element is a good thing by
the way that where people are depending
on you to do your job you're depending
on other people to do their job so you
can collectively win in jiu-jitsu or
track which there's a small element of
that but mainly it's you you you have to
go in you have to take it upon yourself
to get the job done for you and it's
essentially all on you and you learn
that so if you play team sports the
whole time you get less of that you have
a lot there is that in team sports for
sure but it's more prevalent and you get
to arrest
or attract something where you're it's
just you just to you yeah those are
those are good sports very intense very
intense sports and you like I said you
learn how to defend yourself
next one Bennett from Michigan wants to
know Uncle Jake why did you want to be a
Navy SEAL well uncle Jake always wanted
to be some kind of commando ever since
he was a little kid and as soon as he
figured out what the SEAL Teams were
that's what he that's what decided to go
for next one Uncle Jake my son McCoy
wants to know when you will have your
own TV show I don't know but we do have
right now the first warrior kid podcast
so we'll see what happens with the TV
show I would rather have a bunch of kids
reading books rather than watching a TV
show next anderson turns eight today and
asks what would win karate or jiu-jitsu
and the answer that question is
jiu-jitsu actually that's been gone over
a bunch of times now there's a bunch of
good stuff you get from karate too you
learn a lot about discipline and karate
you learn some good striking in karate
so that's good too but if you can try
and train some jiu-jitsu as well so that
you learned some grappling it's a
different type of fighting and when you
put pure striking which is punching and
kicking each other against pure
grappling most of the time it's the
grappler that wins next one how do you
be a warrior well talk about that a lot
in the way of the warrior kid book and
uncle Jake explains too he explains to
mark exactly well kind of not exactly
but he explains to him what a warrior
kit is and he NE explains to him in a
pretty good paragraph I just opened up
the book here's what here's what a
warrior kid is a normal kid doesn't push
himself a warrior kid does a normal kid
doesn't work constantly trying to
improve himself a warrior kid does all
these problems that you cried about
yesterday mark a warrior kid wouldn't
cry about those problems a warrior kid
would
something about those problems so those
are some of the things that a warrior
kid does also if you read though the
code that mark writes at the end of the
book of what it's like to be a warrior
and his he makes his own warrior kid
code that he's going to live by that the
rules that he's going to have and those
are very good rules to be a warrior and
I think I think mark did a great job of
coming up with those rules and I'll tell
you what they are
number one the warrior kid wakes up
early in the morning number two the
warrior kid studies to learn and gain
knowledge and asks questions if he
doesn't understand number three the
warrior kid trains hard exercises and
eats right to be strong and fast and
healthy number four the warrior kid
trains know how to fight so he can stand
up to bullies and protect the weak
number five the warrior kid treats
people with respect and helps out other
people whenever possible number six the
warrior kid keeps things neat and is
always prepared and ready for action
number seven the warrior kid stays
humble number eight the warrior kid
works hard and always does his best
number nine
I am the warrior kid so that's what
being a warrior is especially for a kid
next hi Uncle Jake my name is Chris I'm
8 years old I go to jujitsu class every
week how can I get better the bigger
kids always beat me well that's what
happens in the beginning what you did
too
when you first start off too Jitsu you
get beat all the time
it happened to me when I was starting to
Jitsu and it happens to everyone when
they start you did too
you get beat and the way that you get
better is by keeping training keep
training all the time as much as you can
and that's how you get better and
eventually what's good about jujitsu is
when you know more jujitsu than the
other person you can still beat them
even if they're bigger than you so
that's why I really like jujitsu next my
son wants to know why no matter what the
situation or problem mark has uncle Jake
always says good
so the reason that uncle Jake always
says good when there's a problem is
because he always looks at things in the
most positive light and when he sees
things other people might see something
as a problem he sees them as a challenge
that he can overcome and that's why when
he sees a problem
he just says good let's find a solution
to that problem next hi uncle Jake my
nephew Lincoln is a military kid 2nd
grader loves your book what would uncle
Jake tell Lincoln about being sad when
his friends move away okay so when your
friend friends move away one thing
that's good is that when they're moving
away oh you can still talk to him you
can write them letters you can write
them emails so it's no problem when
friends move away and then the other
thing that's good about when friends
move away is it gives you opportunity to
make new friends
so go shake some hands with some new
kids and get to know them next would you
ever consider making this book into a
movie and is there ever going to be a
part - yes there's going to be a part -
a movie that's not up for me to decide
I'm sure someone will want to make it
into a movie
make it into a cool cartoon maybe a
cartoon will have to say Rebekah asks
what time should a nine-year-old get up
and first of all you need to go to bed
early enough that you get plenty of
sleep and then you need to get up early
enough in the morning that you are ready
for the day and if you're going to try
and do some kind of exercise in the
morning
got to get up a little bit earlier and
if you need to get up and do some extra
studying you got to get up a little bit
earlier so you know get up early enough
that you can have a good start to the
day that's what you want to do next what
is your what is uncle Jake's favorite
gun to shoot uncle Jake's favorite gun
to shoot is the 50 caliber machine gun
which is a big heavy machine gun and
it's very fun to shoot next
Jackson from Ohio says asked uncle Jake
how can I be a better gentleman it's a
great question and the answer that is
treat people how you would like to be
treated so if you follow that rule and
that basically boils down to a word that
we use called respect
you treat people with respect in other
words you treat them how you would like
to be treated that's a great way to be
on the path to becoming a better
gentleman next would uncle Jake have
treated the kid the same if Mark was a
girl or would he have led up well the
answer that is uncle Jake would have
done the same treated if Mark was a girl
and her name was Marsha instead of Mark
uncle Jake would have done the same
thing taught Marsha how to do pull-ups
taught Marsha how to study taught Masha
how to defend herself all the problems
that Mark has in the book are the same I
have three girls that as kids three
girls and one boy they all have had the
same problems so uncle Jake would have
done the same thing and it says would he
have led up and the answer is no uncle
Jake would not have led up because that
would have helped her next I'm eating
good but any tricks or tips to eat
faster it's an interesting question in
the military you learn to eat very fast
first of all there's no reason to eat
faster you can take your time and it's
probably better to take your time when
you eat if you are taking too much time
you're probably doing something else
while you're eating like talking so stop
talking and eat my daughter's asked if
Mark in the book is named after Mark Lee
yes mark Lee was a seal that was worked
with me in Iraq and he was killed in
Iraq and yes mark in the book is named
after Mark Lee it's another way for me
to make sure people remember mark next
what can a kid say if kids use too much
social media to convince their words to
limit use in their free time
well if your friends are using too much
social media I think what you want to
say to them is hey let's go play some
basketball let's go do some pull-ups
let's go wrestle let's go do some
jiu-jitsu let's go find bugs in the yard
let's put that computer screen away and
let's go get better that social media
stuff is not making you a better person
next nine-year-old girl that struggles
to make friends at school and sometimes
feels left out well like I said earlier
it's hard for people to make friends and
sometimes the people that are around
aren't going to be the best friends with
you and that's okay I know different
grades that I had different classes that
I had I didn't always have a bunch of
friends in them sometimes it was hard to
get along with people sometimes they
were interested in things that I wasn't
interested in and what I would do in
those times is just find something that
I am interested in and I would go and do
it so if you're having trouble making
friends
go find a book read a book go look at
what they're doing maybe they're playing
a game that you haven't played before
and you're a little bit shy about
getting involved in it don't be shy
about it walk over and say hey can
someone teach me that can someone help
me learn this and if you open up the
conversation if they're nice to you
maybe you make a new friend
if they're not try and find someone else
that maybe is doing something else that
you could be interested in so I think a
lot of times kids when you're a kid and
I know I felt this way as a kid you feel
like you should always have people
around and if you if you're alone maybe
it's not a good thing
but it's okay it's okay to be alone it's
okay to spend some time by yourself you
don't always need friends everywhere
it's friends are great and it's great
when you make them but you can't force
people to be your friends so I always
found it comfortable or comforting that
if I was by myself I was okay with it
and I don't feel bad about it next
how can i this is from Benjamin how can
I discipline myself to workout every day
and I have a lot of adult asked me this
question too and you know how you
discipline yourself to workout every day
you discipline yourself to workout every
day there's no magic trick it's not easy
you get up and you workout and you do it
every day that's how you do it no magic
trick there what kind of workout routine
for mark and pull-up program well what
if you want to do pull if you want to
get good at pull-ups the best thing to
do is pull-ups you do lots of pull-ups
if if you have a choice between doing
sprints and long runs I like to do
Sprint's more so all these things you
know don't get caught up around kids
don't get caught up around doing some
specific program that's what your
parents are all concerned about I want
to get told the program to do what you
do is you just do a bunch you do eight
sets a set is when you get on the
pull-up bar and you do as many as you
can do that eight times do it 10 times
do it four times do it six times and
then do as many pushups as you can and
do that three or four times maybe five
times so don't get caught up on the
program just go do some stuff it's not
that hard it's well I shouldn't say it's
not that hard it's can be hard when you
start working out and you're going to
get tired and stuff and that's one of
the thing that you do need to do when
you get tired a little bit more that's
what working out is when you get tired
go a little bit more so go do you know I
like to say 8 to 10 sets of pull-ups 8
to 10 sets of push-ups do some squats do
some burpees one thing that's good with
bird pieces do as many purposes you can
in two minutes see how see how many you
can do do that it do that every few days
maybe do that do that on Tuesdays and
Thursdays
many burpees as you can in two minutes
on the other days do some pull-ups do
some push-ups next
what should middle school young men ages
11 to 13 be working on to prepare to
become a productive young man hmm
well these are really easy to answer
study learn learn as much as you can
work or card workout be nice to people
make friends read those the kinds of
things you do the other question about
social media that's not going to help
you become a productive young man what
made you know what you wanted to do in
life so like I said earlier uncle Jake
he always wanted to be a commando next
hmm my kid cares about other kids even
the bullies
he doesn't cattle but doesn't stick up
for himself how can he grow confidence
and courage again people want to grow
confidence and courage confidence and
courage don't grow on trees confidence
and courage grow from work from working
from working out from studying from
learning from participating in sports
that's where you get confidence and
courage from so try all those things out
a four-year-old girl says how are you
doing Uncle Jake Uncle Jake is doing
really good right now and a six-year-old
boy says did any of your friends die in
the Navy and yes uncle Jake lost some
friends very close friends while he was
in the SEAL Teams that's part of being
in the military in the military your job
is to fight a war and in war people die
and it's very sad and very tragic and
also it's the job of the soldiers and
sailors and airmen of Marines to go out
and fight next uncle Jake how long is
Uncle Jake been in the Navy in the book
uncle Jake has been in the Navy for
eight years when he goes to stay at his
sister's house who's Mark's mom nine
year old son and want to know funcle'
Jake ever want to quit during training
no uncle Jake never wanted to quit
and a nine-year-old girl says how can I
get over not doing things perfectly I
get so frustrated when I don't do
something perfect oh that happens to a
lot of people and what you do with that
is you have to realize that wanting
things to be perfect is imperfect you're
not perfect if you want everything to be
perfect and also if you're trying to do
everything perfect you'll never get
anything truly done because you can't do
anything perfectly in the world so look
to be look to do a great job look to do
an outstanding job look to do an
excellent job but when you're going for
perfection it's going to be too hard to
do next how does mark work on
self-awareness and frustration outside
of Brazilian Jujitsu well when you get
frustrated you have to realize you have
to realize the things that you do when
you start getting frustrated so if you
start tensing up your arms or you start
gritting your teeth or you start getting
tears in your eyes you have to realize
what's happening you know those tears in
your eyes are just frustration and then
when you start getting all red in the
face that's just frustration so what you
have to do is realize that you're
getting frustrated and then take a step
back take a deep breath think about
something else
relax so that you don't let that
frustration take over your brain next
eight-year-old girl asks was Uncle Jake
bullied or a wimp like Mark and the
answer is yes all little kids are
getting bullied it happens it happens
too well it happens to just about it
maybe not every single kid in the world
but most kids get bullied especially
when you're 10 years old when you're 10
years old there's always going to be
somebody that's bigger and stronger than
you and you know anyone that's 12 years
old is bigger than you they're stronger
than you there are even a lot of times
smarter than you because they've learned
a little bit more
next is echo gonna make any movies about
mark he made one little short movie
about mark I don't know I don't know
what's going to happen with that will
definitely make more books about mark
every okay kid Lucas that wants to be a
seal same answer you want to be a seal
the advice is study hard work hard train
hard be a good kid
don't get in trouble do the best you can
in school play some sports study hard
that's it
okay the this boy is three and a half
years old and wants to take jiu-jitsu
but the school doesn't allow it until
six years old so the question is should
he go and watch or take kid karate what
do you suggest I would say definitely
let him come watch maybe once a week
just let him go there and be on the mats
and see what it's like and then the
after I've got a karate kid that if they
got a karate program that he can get
into until he can start you Jitsu I
think that'd be good for him so would
wrestling a lot of times if you can find
wrestling they start a little bit
younger and same thing with judo maybe
you can find a judo program they start
them a little bit younger I would do
wrestling first then judo second and
then do those when he's younger until he
can get old enough for jujitsu how do
you stand up to a bully it's all in the
book way the warrior kid you got to
train hard you got to work hard you got
to be in good shape you've and then you
got to stand your ground and guess what
it doesn't mean you're gonna win you
might not win I got the I know this is
Jocko Jocko got beat up when when I that
I got my first fight I got beat and I
got put in a headlock taken down to the
ground I think I was in fourth grade and
taking down to the ground held in the
headlock and punched in the head luckily
it didn't last too long because the
teachers were pretty close so I stood up
to the bully and I got
taken down and put a headlock and punch
in the head you know what though I
didn't die and I felt good about it I
was okay with getting punched in the
head and a lot of times bullies you know
just like in the book bullies the reason
that a bully is because they're mean and
but no one ever challenges them so once
they get challenged a lot of times they
will back down can you teach me to face
my fears well again we have things that
we're afraid of we're afraid of them
because we don't understand them so
prepare as much as you can do as much as
you can to get ready for that thing that
you fear and then when you've practiced
the thing that you fear the final step
you have to do just like in the book is
you have to step you have to you have to
go for it that's what you eventually
have to do can you teach me how to
recognize things that aren't good like
poison ivy and stuff that's from Emma
these questions were all from Emma yeah
Emma I can't teach you because I'm on a
podcast right now but luckily there's so
many good books out there and you can
make little flashcards just like Mark
does in the book with pictures of all
the bad stuff out there in nature and
that way you know what poison ivy looks
like let's see most important thing
about being a warrior kid I think the
most important thing about being a
warrior and a warrior kid is to be
humble and to be humble means you don't
think you're the best thing in the world
we shouldn't think that the minute that
you think that you aren't trying to get
better anymore you aren't trying to
improve yourself you're treating people
poorly because you think you're better
than them so there's a key word it's
called humility and you always want to
stay humble 11 year old that wants to go
towards the goal of being a seal same
thing or card workout study hard
favorite Brazilian Jiu Jitsu move for
uncle Jake what do you think uncle
Jake's favorite Brazilian Jiu Jitsu move
his I think it's the rear naked choke I
haven't confirmed this yet and uncle
Jake joined the Navy after he got done
with high school he was 18 years old
Oh Lucas wants to be a seal or a ranger
but he has a hard time controlling his
temper and following orders from his
superior uncle Jake would say that in
the SEAL Teams and in the Rangers if you
have a bad temper you're not going to
make it so watch and you know what a lot
of kids have bad tempers I had a bad
temper when I was a kid and at some
point you got to realize that that bad
temper is not good and so what you have
to do is learn to control your temper so
it's what I talked about earlier if you
start feeling that temper if you start
feeling your face getting red and you
start phew most tears coming in your
eyes you gotta say to yourself oh I'm
losing my temper I'm actually being weak
right now by losing my temper so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take a breath
I'm going to step back I'm going to calm
down even if you have to walk away and
go in your room for a minute and just
sit down and take a breath and get
control of your temper any older you get
the better you'll get it controlling
your temper and then as followed as far
as following orders from your superiors
in the military SEAL Teams Rangers you
absolutely have to listen to the people
that you work for and it's the same
thing in the civilian sector so a good
way to practice that is by listening to
what your parents say now you might not
think what your parents say you might
not feel like doing it you might not
feel like cleaning your room so it's
good practice to look at your dad when
he says to clean your room and say no
problem dad I got it
that's good practice for when you get in
the military now you should also grab a
conversation with your dad and say hey
dad why is this important and have them
explain it to you so that way you're
more of a team than just your dad
barking orders at you once you
understand why it's important that will
help you get motivated to do the job
that's in front of you and we got a
bunch of questions from a guy named Mike
Hurley Mike Curley from it he's a
teacher so I'm gonna have to go through
these pretty pretty quickly
first one is from I think this one's
from Mike as well how did you get the
idea of writing way of the warrior kid a
lot of the kids books that I read went
from my own kids I didn't like them very
much do I have any new books coming out
the new book is coming out in May of
2018 favorite book I have written well
I've only written two books so far one
is called way the warrior kid which is
for kids and the other one is called
extreme ownership which is for adults
and I like them both did I relate to
Marc when I was younger yes I think
that's one of the reasons why this book
is so populous because everyone can
relate to Marc there's no one that woke
up and were in and they went when they
were 10 years old they would've asked at
everything
no everyone has problems with different
things what inspired me to become an
author I wanted to kind of teach some of
the lessons that I had learned let's see
kay asks how to improve your grades in
math how to improve your marks you've
got to study that's the thing just like
just like just like mark in the book he
didn't study his times tables and
therefore he didn't know them so make
your flashcards and study and then the
other big thing that I learned from
being in the Navy is when you don't
understand something you have to ask the
question in class you have to ask your
teacher you know why you don't want to
ask it because you're embarrassed cause
you feel awful if I ask this question
that means I'm stupid and people will
laugh at me it's not true and even if
they do laugh at you you know what it
doesn't matter because when you take the
test you're going to do better so don't
be embarrassed to ask questions ask
questions and study hard
next what mental challenges did you face
training to be a Navy SEAL well there's
all kinds of challenges that you face
trying to become a Navy SEAL and I'm
trying to think of my personal ones
well there's a bunch and the biggest
thing for me is I wasn't great at
anything I wasn't the fastest runner I
wasn't the fastest swimmer I wasn't
fastest at the obstacle course I wasn't
the best shot with a pistol rifle so
everything for me was hard and I had to
work hard at everything that I did and
so for me there was never a mental rest
some guys they might not be the best
runner but they're a great swimmer so
during the swim it was kind of easy for
him I didn't really have any brakes so
that was probably my biggest mental
challenge next is from a reader how am I
supposed to stop missing one of my
friends that live really far away and
we've been friends for over five years
okay well when you miss one of your
friends the best thing to do is write to
them write them letters call them if you
can write them emails and keep in touch
with them and snow it's normal to miss
your friends when they leave so you
shouldn't even try and stop missing them
just write them letters tell them what's
going on and maintain contact with them
next uncle dear Uncle Jake you are so
wise you're the only person who knows
the answer to this question how do I
stop eating junk food I can't stop help
me so actually the only person that can
stop you from eating junk food isn't
uncle Jake it's you it's you you're the
one that has to stop eating junk food
and the way you do it isn't as hard as
you think
actually it's simple it's not easy but
it's simple the junk food that you want
to put into your mouth don't put it into
your mouth don't do it you know it's
weak food like Ecco said earlier it's
weak food and we don't want to eat that
weak food we want the strong food so
when it when you get tempted to eat that
weak food don't do it don't do it don't
take one bite don't even say I'm just
gonna have one cookie instead of four
don't have any because once you have one
it's all known so the way that you
stopped from eating junk food is by stop
eating junk food that's what you need to
do
next why did I write decide to write
this story because I thought there was a
lot of kids that could learn from it
even my own kids that's one of the main
reasons I wrote it
do I have any other books coming out yes
May of 2018 I also have a book coming
out it's more of an adult book coming
out in October what's the favorite book
I've written I already answered that one
what have I ever been in Mark situation
when I was a child yes like I said of
course it was hard I couldn't do a bunch
of pull-ups I was not one of the
stronger kids I had trouble in school
sometimes so every I I relate to
everything that Mark went through and I
saw my own kids go through those same
troubles how can I stop eating so much
junk food I already answered that stop
eating junk food how can I convince my
parents to get a puppy now if I could
answer that question I'd probably be the
most popular person in the world it's
really hard because what kids don't
realize is that puppies are a huge huge
responsibility and it's I have had dogs
a lot in my life and I have kids a lot
in my life
and had four kids and I will tell you
that the responsibility of a dog is
almost as much as the responsibility of
having a kid so it's not really easy to
get a to own a dog so the best thing you
can do I think if you want to convince
your parents to let you get a puppy
which is no guarantee the best thing you
can do is be a good kid work hard
show responsibility get good grades in
school help with the chores help with
the cleaning up because the bottom line
is when you when you get a puppy there's
one big issue with a puppy that no one
wants to talk about and that's puppy
poopoo right what's going to happen
who's going to who's going to clean up
the puppy poopoo in the yard is it going
to be you because your parents don't
think you're going to do it and that's
one of the main reasons they don't want
to get you a puppy because they don't
want to pick up puppy poopoo
so show that you're responsible and how
can I convince my parents to allow me to
be on social media more than I am now I
would say your parents are doing a great
job the social media is not going to
help you
and don't try and convince them of that
work on the puppy instead that's going
to be better for you next my brother
bullies me and makes me do everything
for him and if not he says he will take
something from me and hide it or hurt me
well you got to negotiate with your
older brother first of all he's running
around being a bully that's not cool at
all
I would talk to your parents about it
and say that you're being bullied and
tell your parents what's going on but I
would also talk to your brother about it
and say you know why are you doing this
to me why are you treating me like this
do you think it's fun for me and if he
doesn't seem to care well then you might
have to go into some kind of guerilla
warfare against your brother and start
maybe if he wants you to do something
for him maybe you don't do it perfectly
do it a little bit less than perfect or
maybe take a long time to do it and it's
really hard it's really hard growing up
in a house with older brothers and older
sisters that bully you so talk to your
parents about it and as always start
doing a bunch of pull-ups try and learn
some jiu-jitsu learn to stand up for
yourself
study hard and also the worst case
scenario in this if you let's say that
you can't stop your brother from
bullying you because that's just the way
it is and your parents aren't around
enough you know what you can do from
this situation is you can learn from it
you can learn from your brother by the
way he mistreats you you can learn that
you're never going to do that to other
people you're never going to do that to
other kids and that you're going to
treat people much better than your
brother treats you so even if you can't
stop him and he ends up bullying you
until he moves out of the house he's
taught you such a valuable lesson about
life and about human beings that it'll
be worth it in the long run so I know
it's tough I know it's hard but learn as
much as you can from it and in the
meantime also take those steps so that
you can stop them good luck with that
buddy it's a tough one
question 1 what is the meaning of life I
guess that you are not playing around
with any easy questions for Uncle Jake
Uncle Jake Uncle Jake will tell you that
the meaning of his life is to try and
help other people and try and do good in
the world that's what he's trying to do
with his life how do I stop my friend
from laughing so much I would say if
your friend is laughing so much I don't
know why you'd want to stop them unless
they're getting in trouble and if
they're getting in trouble just go sit
in a seat that's not so close to them in
class I had a friend named Ryder when I
was a kid and he would add laughing
attacks and he would laugh so hard that
he would get kicked out of the classroom
and I remember one time he was laughing
so hard he got kicked out of the
classroom and after about five minutes
went by I looked to the door where the
window was there was a window in the
door to the classroom and his face came
up into the into the window he was still
laughing hysterically after five minutes
so sometimes people laugh and and
normally people laugh hard when you're
not supposed to that's one of the things
that makes laughing hard funny is you're
not supposed to be laughing so yeah just
move away from him and tell him to calm
down or else you can't hang out with him
during classes most pushups okay no
matter how much stress I put on myself
the most pushups I can do is fifty how
do i improve just keep doing push-ups if
you can do fifty right now do two or
three steps of fifty and keep doing
push-ups that's how you get blood better
better at any of these things can you
join the Navy at 12 years old no you
can't join the Navy until your turn 18
let's see how we doing on time oh I
think we're going to make it I'm trying
to keep this to an hour everybody
because I know I got what great letter
yesterday from a kid that rode said hey
thanks for writing away the warrior kid
and putting all the lessons in it that
you talk about on your podcast but we
don't have to listen your whole podcast
which gets boring to learn the lesson so
honesty yes kids are always honest and
that's
while kids most of the time are honest
what is the question on this one was
this book a kid and adult guide to
becoming strong and healthy because the
books talks about things what mark needs
to do to become smart and fit yes that's
exactly what the book was for the book
was a guidebook for kids to become
smarter stronger faster and better
people
that's that's what the book is about and
also I wish I would had this book when I
was a kid let's see I have a question
about the book I always fight with my
brother what should I do
well that's that's a tough one because
kids fight with their with their
siblings I had two sisters growing up
and we got in fights all the time and I
wish I could go back and be more mature
because I was you know a kid and when
you look back you say what was I doing
fighting with my two sisters that's
ridiculous
so what you need to do is look at the
things I this is one thing you can do to
start with look at the things you're
fighting about and I can pretty much
guarantee that the things you're
fighting about are the most silly and
ridiculous things right like what what
piece of carrot do you get I want this
carrot no I want that carrot and then
you're fighting about it what where are
you going to put your head on the couch
don't put your head near me don't put
your foot near me right that's the kind
of things that kids fight about so what
we have to do is instead of letting
those things annoy you just say you know
what he's going to put his head over
here I'm just going to move my head a
little bit there's a Great War hero that
we had that I talked to named captain
Charlie plumb and he was in the Vietnam
War he was a fighter pilot in Vietnam
War and he was shot down he was held in
a prison camp for six years and one of
the things that he said is if you can
imagine you know you you think it's hard
living with your brother because you
have to spend you know a couple hours a
day in the same house imagine being in a
little tiny prison cell for six years
with other people day in day out 24
hours a day
so what they figured out was if they got
mad or they got annoyed at something
someone else was doing
they didn't blame the other person they
blamed themselves so you don't want to
fight with your brother stop blaming him
for being annoying and start blaming
yourself for getting annoyed and just
try and be a little bit more mature
about it next I enjoyed your book and go
to medical school and I don't want to
lose touch with people hey if you're
this happens when kids move around just
get out get their address and start
writing letters that's what you need to
do let's see how do you improve and
pull-ups do pull-ups how do you improve
and running run how do you overcome your
fears talked about that one you train
you practice and then you face them and
what are healthy foods other than milk I
think the key thing with healthy foods
is to eat things that are made by nature
not by man so if it comes in a big
plastic package in a box and it and when
you look at the list of ingredients it's
a hundred and forty seven words that you
can't pronounce that's the thing you've
got to watch out for but if it's a
carrot or it's an orange or it's a steak
or it's a piece of chicken and the
ingredients in the chicken are chicken
and the ingredients in mistake are steak
and the ingredients in the fish is fish
and the ingredients in the in the
lettuce is lettuce those are the things
you want to try and eat those are the
healthiest things major question for
uncle Jake
need more money for fidgets spinners and
a may merch Pocky and robox but my
parents won't let me have money for it
what should I do
really easy get a job that's what you do
when you need money you get a job you
don't get things for free you have to
work so if you need money for all these
ridiculous things that you want to spend
it on which by the way they're all
ridiculous you should save your money
for some things like pull-up bars or
just save your money for your future
save it for when you go to college but
you're not going to get more your
parents aren't obligated to give you
money for junk which is what you want it
for your parents are actually smart for
not giving you money I wouldn't give you
money to buy that junk
so if you want money get a job mowing
lawns pulling out weeds throwing
newspapers whatever it is you got to do
but if you want to buy junk you got to
do with your own money not your parents
next question if someone's too lazy to
get up in the morning and doesn't want
to get woken up by someone who's
smashing utensils or anything in your
eardrum what what is the more easier way
to get up what is an easier way to get
up and you are talking about yourself
that's from our well what you need to do
in those situations is get an alarm
clock when the alarm clock goes off get
up and get out of bed and if you still
feel tired in the morning then you need
to go to bed earlier at night so it's
never easy to get up in the morning get
up getting up in the morning is hard
that's why it's such an edge over normal
people because normal people they want
to sleep they want to sleep and sleep
and sleep and when you sleep you're not
being productive now of course you need
sleep it's good for you to sleep you're
going to be stronger the more you sleep
the stronger you're going to be but if
you sleep and you don't work out and you
sleep and you miss your schoolwork and
you sleep and you're just being lazy
that's not going to be good for you so
get an alarm clock set your alarm clock
when your alarm clock goes off get up
and get out of bed how do I stop eating
food that's not healthy you stop eating
the food that's not healthy that's it
also tell your mom another thing for
those of you to ask you this question
tell your mom and dad not to buy that
food you don't want it in the house
that's what you need to do tell your
parents you don't want the ice cream in
the house you don't want the Cheetos in
the house you don't want that what's
another good one and what you don't want
the chocolate chip cookies in the house
now
if you're out and you just had a nice
you know at ball game and you play
baseball or you played a soccer game or
a football game and your mom stops at a
shop on the way home and says hey son
you played a great game you want a
chocolate chip cookie and you go yeah
that sounds good little reward that's
okay that's great but if you have those
chocolate chip cookies in your house and
you just got done playing two hours
worth of video games and you're feeling
a little bit hungry so you go in the
kitchen there's a chocolate chip cookie
box and you eat nine of them
that's not good so don't do that or soda
or Leah soda is horrible you shouldn't
you should beg your parents not to bring
soda in the house if you're if your
parents bring soda in the house you
should say oh do you not like me because
why are you feeding me this this is
poison don't feed me poison I want water
just bring me some water mom and dad
please let's see how to start a good
habit such as working out you start
working out okay next
how old was uncle Jake when he joined
the SEAL Teams he was 18 can you join at
10 years old no how was uncle Jake's
experience in the SEAL Teams he loved it
all uncle Jake I have a question for you
how do you get stronger and not get
bullied
I already answered that one you work out
you trained jujitsu you trained boxing
you trained wrestling trained judo and
you stand up to those bullies like I
said not always going to win but you'll
win in the long run five-year-old wants
to know why you have to do pull-ups to
be a war your kid you don't have to do
pull-ups to be a warrior kid but
pull-ups is a great exercise like
there's some people that maybe they have
some issue that maybe they got a hurt
shoulder or a hurt arm and they can't do
pull-ups
and that's okay you can still be a
warrior kid but if you if your arms are
healthy and you can do pull-ups they're
a great thing to do because it means you
can handle your own weight it means you
can carry yourself it means you can take
care of yourself so that's why pull-ups
are great a great exercise and they're
also I've read a lot of stuff that if
kids can do pull-ups it did it helps
their overall health so pulps are great
for you it's a great exercise if you can
do them Dylan if you're injured or
you've got some kind of an issue where
you can't do them try and find a
different exercise that you can do and
focus on that one next
questions from six-year-old boy McGee
his uncle Jake real know Uncle Jake is a
fictional character
how old is Uncle Jake Uncle Jake in the
book as I think about 26 years old and
what keeps Uncle Jake moving during
really hard times when the going gets
tough for Uncle Jake you know what Uncle
Jake does he actually enjoys it he knows
he's being challenged and so he pushes
himself next when you're working out and
feeling under the weather should you
still give a hundred percent well
actually if you're feeling sick maybe
it's time for a little rest if you just
don't feel a hundred percent like maybe
you're feeling a little tired a little
mopey that day still get in there and
you're not gonna be able to give 100%
every day no one can give a hundred
percent every day you'll run out a
percent so you got to save some of that
percent so you can't give a hundred
percent of your day but give what you
can do what you can get in there make it
happen
how is Uncle Jake doing in college uncle
Jake is doing outstanding in college
did Uncle Jake respond a Marx letter yes
he did and what was a response you'll
find out in May when the next book comes
out how uncle Jake's knows so many
languages and how does he know the
warrior code in the book Uncle Jake
studies languages when you're when
you're in the military and you go to
other countries a lot of times you'll
study the language that they speak there
so you can communicate with the local
people so that's how Uncle Jake knows a
little bit of a lot of different
languages and how does he know the
warrior codes in the book he studies and
reads about the past and reads about
history and reads about what other
warriors were like so that he can figure
out what they did well so he can do the
same thing how many pull-ups can Uncle
Jake do Uncle Jake can do 75 pull-ups as
Uncle Jake ever jumped off a bridge into
a lake before many times what was your
job in the Neal in the Navy SEALs and
what team were you on well this is Jocko
and Jocko I was
on my job I started off as a radio man
which I meant I carried the radio and
then I became an officer which means I
would be in charge of a seal squad or a
seal platoon or seal task unit and then
the SEAL Teams I was on I was on SEAL
team 1 SEAL team 2 SEAL team 3 until
team 7 question from warrior kid Aden
what kind of workout would you recommend
for 12 year old boy to get stronger
push-ups pull-ups sit-ups squats and I
would do a lot of those like I said 8 to
10 sets and that's what you build up to
when you first start you might only be
able to do 3 or 4 sets and then
sometimes you goo one day you do
pull-ups eight sets of poles the next
day you do push-ups eight sets of
push-ups the next day you do squats
eight sets of squats and just keep
working next what is the middle name
uncle Jake's middle name could have to
find that one out in the second book and
what was it like to be in the Navy SEALs
being in the SEAL Teams is so fun and it
was a great job and I loved every second
of it
and uncle Jake loved the SEAL Teams as
well and it's also a dangerous job so a
lot of people think that they want to
join the SEAL Teams because it's a lot
of fun and it looks cool and you get to
do cool stuff but you also got to
remember it's a very dangerous job and
being it being in the SEAL Teams isn't
just fun all the time it's hard work a
very hard work and it's very dangerous
sometimes so if it's something that a
lot of a lot of kids have been asking
about how do what do I do to get ready
for the SEAL Teams you need to make sure
that you have the right attitude about
danger because it's a very dangerous job
sometimes but it's also a lot of fun
will uncle Jake come back to mentor mark
in his teenage years yes he will he's
going to mentor him for about six books
until he's done with his high school
career
let's see Nolan and Brady asked how are
you so smart well I'm not that smart
Uncle Jake is very smart but the way you
get smart is by reading that's that to
me that's one of the most important
reading and studying that's how you get
smart so read and study as much as you
can and find books that you're
interested in
I read a lot of books about war because
I'm very interested in war but those are
the those are the kind of books that I'm
interested in and there's a lot of books
about that but anything that you're
interested in if you're interested in
cars read about cars and how they work
if you're interested in computers read
about how computers work if you're
interested in space travel read books
about space travel but the more you read
the smarter you're going to be let's see
how can I get my little brother more
interested in the story and reading the
book if he doesn't like reading that
much we get to them sit down with them
and read it to them five-year-old a
question here what should I do when my
friends don't want to play with me at
school I say you play by yourself I say
you go over and find a pull-up bar and
find the swing set and do things that
you can just do by yourself and every
once in a while go over and see what
they're doing and ask them about it and
see if you know if they need anyone else
to play with them and if they don't then
that's fine like I said it's it's okay
to be alone sometimes and and sometimes
kids the owner of the hardest thing is
one of the another reason why I wrote
this book is that being a kid is hard
and kids can be really mean and when I
was a kid I felt both sides of that
sometimes I had kids be mean to me and
sometimes I was meeting the other kids
like I said because I was immature they
didn't know so the older I got the nicer
you can be but sometimes when you're you
know six and seven and eight years old
sometimes kids can be really mean and
that doesn't mean you should be me in
fact what it means you should be nice so
if you got kids that don't want to play
with you that's okay
spend some time by yourself look for
some other kids that maybe do want to
hang out a little bit what do you do on
a daily basis as a Navy SEAL it's really
hard to describe what you do as a Navy
SEAL on a daily basis because it changes
everyday sometimes you're parachuting
sometimes you're shooting guns
sometimes you're blowing things up
sometimes you're working out sometimes
you're doing
to work sometimes you're traveling
sometimes you're going on long patrols
which is like a hike through the desert
or through the jungle or through the
mountains sometimes you're in the water
doing diving sometimes you're it's just
a very it's very hard to describe what
you do every single day because it's
different every day and that's one of
the things that makes the job very
exciting and fun is that you get to do
different stuff all the time
what tips and tricks would you have for
getting up and getting after it when I'm
not feeling it that's from Gavin I think
that was a video 1 Gavin said he's not
feeling it sometimes those are the
special days where you actually have to
do it so the days when you're not
feeling it are the days where you get
better the days that you don't want to
study those the days you get smarter the
days that you don't want to work out but
you work out anyways those are the days
you get stronger so when you're not
feeling it tell yourself oh good it's an
opportunity for me to step up overcome
some weakness and get better what made
Uncle Jake and Jocko want to be a Navy
SEAL like I said always wanted to be a
commando kids in class want to know what
Jake's purpose is for going to college
what's his new goal well uncle Jake has
been an enlisted guy in the SEAL Teams
and he wants to become an officer he
wants to move into more of a leadership
role and so what he's going to do is
he's going to go to college he's going
to get his degree and then he's
hopefully going to go back to the SEAL
Teams as an officer so he can be in
charge of a seal platoon that's one of
his goals the inspiration for mark like
I said was Mark Lee and that's who he's
named after but also mark represents all
kinds of kids even myself and my own
kids is you know it's like I said it's
hard being a kid so mark is a
representation of some of the struggles
that kids face and then the struggles
aren't going to be the exact same right
some kids might be good at math but
they're not good at spelling some kids
might be good at math and spelling but
they can't memorize any history facts so
your challenges are going to be
different some kids might be good at
pull-ups but they're not fast runners
some kids might be fast runners but
they're not good at throwing a baseball
so the challenges are different but how
you overcome those challenges are the
same and that's through hard work and
practice so that was the inspiration and
like I said the Uncle Jake to me was
always in my mind just the ultimate seal
and that's what I tried to make him to
be like then mark was an average kid
that's going to do above-average things
through hard work and through discipline
and so those are the questions that we
had for this podcast and appreciate all
those questions that everyone sent me I
know it's a lot of stuff out there
and I know that it was hard for me to go
through them all but I was really
thankful that we got all those questions
and I'm sure we'll have some more
questions in the future thanks for
reading the book thanks for showing all
those cool pictures of everyone out
there reading the book and doing their
time stables and studying and using
flashcards and doing pull ups that's
great for me to see and like I said I
like to team kids do things where
they're getting better so thanks for
reading the book and and telling your
friends about the book I appreciate it
and most of all thanks for training hard
thanks for studying hard and thanks for
working hard to get stronger smarter
faster and better so stay on the path of
discipline and keep getting after it
until next time from Uncle Jake and echo
and Jocko out